free throws that he's been shooting all
game long
he has been magnificent at the line
[Music]
50 points only the seventh player
in the history of the finals to have a
50-point game
elgin baylor rick barry michael jordan
jerry west
lebron james bob pettit and giannis
antonico
[Applause]
a rare miss tonight and the suns will
call their final timeout
down seven with 8.9 remaining
the players exhausted will go to their
benches
[Applause]
the milwaukee bucks on the verge
8.9 seconds remain and what has been
another thrilling game between these two
teams
finals featuring two teams that had not
been here in decades
of finals without the familiar star
power that we've had in recent years
but that's what i call star power and a
huge smile
they put the clock back to 9.5 seconds
[Applause]
50 points 14 rebounds five blocked shots
50 of 105 points nearly half the team's
total
now jeff with 9.5 remaining
a miracle finish would have to obviously
happen for finish to pull it out
and again they're out of timeouts
that's why you've got to concentrate on
the details
[Applause]
booker turns shoots fires shot won't go
chuckle the rebound
and that'll do it it's over
the bucks have done it the long wait has
ended after a half century
the milwaukee bucks are nba champions
once again
you
the emotions come pouring out one of the
greatest nights in milwaukee sports
history
ends in a coronation
and the brilliance of the young man from
athens
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
another crushing finish for devin booker
and the phoenix suns
after a superb season
this extraordinary story of this
extraordinary young man
gives him his nba title the greek freak
is a greek nba champion
[Applause]
guys we've seen a lot of amazing
performances
this ranks as one of the all-time
greatest it absolutely does
we've witnessed lebron james for so long
but we've seen a guy put up lebron james
type numbers
especially after the fact that he was
supposed to be out the rest of the way
after that scary injury and then the
defensive
component and effort and example
that he set i mean he was
sprinting and blocking and running the
floor
and the only guy who had it going
offensively
the burden was great and he was up to
the task
b.j tucker acquired mid-season a big
part of the success of this team in the
playoffs
he has such a sense of loyalty his
family first
but to the bucks in the city of
milwaukee he's talked about everyone has
a different path to a title
i'm not judging anyone but for me i want
to do it with the team that took a
chance on me
a city that welcomed me and with
teammates that i went through the highs
and lows with
i feel like it just means more
these two teammates long years together
are nba champions together
[Applause]
[Applause]
this is going to be some wild night in
downtown milwaukee
last time the bucks won a championship
1971.
again they're saying that's 65 000.
he wanted to do it in the city that he
now calls home
mission accomplished brianna sapiracupo
and this is always the fun part guys the
celebrations these phenomenal
grown men behave with the exuberance of
children
it's just so happy at the years of
sacrifice the years of hard work the
years of pain
and the emotions come pouring out
[Applause]
right now let's